bonjour je suis Philippe qui écoute
vice-président Recherche et Innovation à
l'université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et je suis
également chercheur au Latmos impliqué
dans les dans les développements de nano
satellite l'Atmos c'est un laboratoire
historique qui fait suite à un
laboratoire créé en 1958 et qui a
toujours travaillé dans le spatial et
donc le l'Atmos veut dire atmosphère
observation spatiale donc comme son nom
l'indique on s'intéresse à l'atmosphère
terrestre et planétaire donc des
planètes du système solaire alors sur
les formations on voit qu'aujourd'hui
notre expertise peut être vraiment
utilisé à former les étudiants et on a
d'une part participé à la formation en
licence professionnelle une L3 qui était
un besoin des entreprises et on a monté
aussi un master qui s'appelle master
newspace donc comme son nom l'indique
qui va qui va permettre aux étudiants de
travailler dans le spatial mais aussi
avec une une vision un peu un peu
nouvelle de ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
[Musique]
alors bonjour je suis Louis de Chazot je
suis assistant ingénieur électronicien
au Latmos alors devant moi j'ai à gauche
inspire 7 un anneau satellite et à
droite une fusée sonde Véronique du
centre du service d'Aéronomie donc un
ancêtre du l'Atmos pour le moment le
l'Atmos a deux nano satellite le premier
qui est parti le 21 janvier 2021 et le
deuxième que vous avez ici une fire 7 7
qui est parti le 15 avril et
actuellement le deuxième inspire 7 7 est
en cours de validation en orbite alors
le travail d'études climatique il a
commencé avec
uvsq7 donc le premier en récupérant les
données de du bilan radiatif donc
l'étude du climat et les données pour
inspire 7 sont en cours de récupération
il faut imaginer deux Rubik's Cube on a
nos antennes en haut et en bas pour
faire la communication et nous avons les
panneaux solaires latéraux sur tous les
côtés pour alimenter notre satellite et
vous avez les petits cadrans blancs ce
sont les capteurs qui vont récupérer nos
données scientifiques alors ça permet de
justement faire une cartographie du
bilan radiatif sur l'ensemble de la
terre
il y a un troisième satellite donc UBS
Q7 NG qui est prévu pour 2025 et qui va
emporter à bord donc toujours les
capteurs pour le bilan radiatif mais
aussi des capteurs pour l'étude des gaz
à effet de serre ces études elles vont
servir justement à pouvoir surveiller et
étudier le changement climatique en
fonction du réchauffement climatique et
principalement sur certaines zones
ciblées